で これは真相で言えば同じディッティなんです
見なんです 同じ見なんですが
まだ違う働きをする イダンサッチャっていうのは
これは本物だ これは真実だ
これは事実だと自分の心で決めちゃうんです
決めちゃって その生き方で
その事実で それでずっともう自分の人生設計しちゃうんです
で 私たちも知識人 いつでもそういうふうにいっちゃうんです
何か新しいニュース入ったら
あ そうですか 今 そういうことですかと
もうそれが事実だと認めてるんですね
聞いた瞬間に それで違うニュース入っちゃうと
もう捨てる そんなことはないんだ
そういうふうに我々人に性格決めつけてるでしょ
本人の性格と関係なく
社会はあなたはこういうものだ
あなたはこういうものだともう決めつけてあげるんですね
大きな恩恵ですけど それで本人がもし違うことでもしたら認めないんですね
そんなことはありえないんだと
なぜなら私がそう決めてるんだからという感じなんです
これ 日本の社会ではもうものすごくあることで
人のこと平気で決めつけてあげると
それ眼科だから 眼科で言ったって眼科状態だから
私も全然治すおうともしない
よくよく見えますけどね
言ってることは全く嘘だと
根拠ないと私には見えるんですね
ただ自分勝手に人のことを決めつけて
偉そうに言ってるんだと
それで聞く側はもう同じ病気だからよく認めるんだ
うなずきながら そうですか
そうですね そういうことなのかと
で 僕はまあそれよく聞こえますから
まあ相手がないんだから一人で笑うしかないし
一人で笑ったらおかしいと思われますから
顔では笑ってないんです
で この科学の世界もいつでもいろいろトラブルがなぜあるかというと
あの科学者さえ何か決めちゃったら
それこそ科学的な事実だと
もう決めつけちゃって
ちょっとでもその意見と違う意見が出てくると
混乱するわ 攻撃するわ
戦うわ 論文は次から次へと書くわ
それでやがて自分たちが範田氏的は正しいとなるでしょうね
そうすると じゃあこれは事実だ
それでもう捕まっちゃうんだ
それがそれに違う意見出しちゃったらまた戦うわけ
だから科学の世界さえも保守的で
自分の意見 立場 考え方
方法論などなどにはもうわずかでも違うことを言っちゃったら
もう科学者ではないと
昔はね このアカデミーからもう破門までするんです
あなたも破門だと 有名なシグムンド・フロイトにしたっても
かなり厳しい試練いろいろありましたから
彼がね 生命っていうのはやっぱり性欲ですよと
衝動っていうのは そんなことはありえないんだと
すっごいもう攻撃と もう恥ずかしいことを言うな
すごい偉い清らかな人類という格好つけちゃって
結局何ですかというと
このヴィクトリアンの
なんて言いますか 道徳的なね
こんな変な道徳観 キリスト教作ったでしょうに
イエス様もあっちこっち遊んでる女の人なんか弟子入れしてすごい仲良くしていたのに
ですから これは後でこの
やっぱり戒律がありますからね
イエス様みたいにもう差別感がなくて
もう年金持ちであろうが貧しい人であろうが
どこでも行って自我がなくてね
あの美しい自由な姿がもうかっこ悪いんですね
だから厳密でガリガリで排他的で
我々は行者修行者たちで
あなた方はそうじゃないという排他的な差別的な宗教でなければいけませんと言って
これは 2番目のシーラブダカラの汗なんですね
そこですっごい厳密にこの戒律ができちゃったんですね
イエス様を教えたのは罪を赦しましょうよと
こんなもう誰でもやってることだから
まあ許してあげましょうと
それはもう捨てる 慈悲真実を
尊い教えをサッと捨てる
だからこの何といいますか
この不倫をした女の人をね
石で流してね 殺そうとしたところ
イエス様言って ああそうですか
教典にそう書いてあるんですかと
そう書いてあるんだから
我々ユダヤ教では だからこの女の人を殺さなくちゃいけないんだと
ああはい 分かりました
どうぞやってください
でも最初の石だけは何も罪を犯してない人が投げてください
それからみんな一斉に石を投げて
その女の人を殺してください
あのひと言ばにすごい真理を語っているでしょうね
最初の石を取るのは何の罪も犯してない人だったらいいということを言ったら
誰も石を取ろうとしないんです
でしたと まあそうではなかったと
ユダヤ人というのはすごい優劣意識だからね
まあどうか分かりませんだけどね
まあストーリーぐらいでもそういう作ってるんだからね
それで女の人は殺されずに済みましたと
だからそんなことでね
人を裁くなということなんですね
人っていうのはみんな弱いもんだから間違いは犯す
あなた間違いを犯したんではないかという権利
誰にもない 言う人間違いを犯す
ですから許してあげることしか道がないんです
まあそうですね まあ私も時々はやります
間違いを犯しますけど
でもいいということじゃないんだから気をつけましょうよと
今度からはやらないようにしましょうと
それぐらいのことでしょう
そうするためにはすごい愛情が必要なんです
間違いを起こした人に対して
で それでこのそれは捨てられてね
イエス様の尊い教え捨てられて
このまたこの開運宗的なね
宗教が出てきて しきたりしきたりしきたりで
で その科学者が当時でシグムンド・フロイトの話でしたからね
それを信じてるんです
でも自分たちが科学者だとまた看板もかけてるんです
シグムンド・フロイトは科学者じゃないんだと
おかしい話でしょうね
当時シグムンド・フロイトを崇拝していた人々が科学者だと言ってるだけで
結局何かのことが真理だとしがみついて捕まっていて
嘘をついてるだけで本人が言ってるのは嘘だとわかってないんです
頭がおかしくなる でもいまだにシグムンド・フロイト知ってることは同じ事実でしょう
シグムンド・フロイトはその当時言葉がなかったんだから
性欲とかなんとか言っただけであって
性欲に浸ったって何したってもこの体の刺激ですからね
仏教から言えば刺激を受けてその刺激求めていることは生きることなんです
ですから 彼が言ったのは事実なんです
そんな尊いことは何もないんだと
単なるこの物体が刺激くれということだけ
何でもいいんだ 刺激であるならば
それは存在であるんですね
そこでちょっとおかしくなっちゃったら心の問題が
現れると それはそういうことだと認めたら落ち着きますよと彼が言ったことなんですね
結構真実に近いことを言ったし
でも当時では いえ 生命は尊いだと
それこそ真実だと あのギャルリを殺した宗教の考え方を信じてるんで
それこそ気が付いてない
いかに恥ずかしい話でしょうね
人間の世界で ですから
その病気が我々にあります
何か知ったらすぐ あ それはそれ通りだ
それは事実だ すぐそこで我々はこの落ち着きを探す
そこはものすごい問題なんです
じゃあどうすればいいかと
人の話聞かない方がいいんですかと
何もなかなか難しいんです
人の話を聞く 人の話を聞かない方がいいと言ったって
そんなわけじゃないし
じゃあやらなきゃ科学やらあーだこーだで読めなくちゃいいんですか？そんなわけでもないし
でも一人も真実を言ってるわけでもないでしょうに
もう新聞雑誌読んでいたっても
朝のニュース 次のニュースは変わってるでしょうに
随分変わってるんでしょうし
ですから この まあほどほどに見た方が
ほどほどに理解した方がよろしいし
それで心に必要なのは
今の状況ではこういう意見
こういう結論 結論にはなるんだけどというぐらいのことなんです
こういう結論だということではないんです
こういう結論にはなるんだけどと置いておく
それでまた新しい事実が発見しちゃったら
そういう結論になるんだけどと
それだったら そういうふうにいつでも心はオープンコンディションにしておかなくちゃいけないんです
捕まったらそれで終わり
オープンコンディションでしておくと
その人にはもうどんな人よりもすごい知恵がある
社会にね 例えばみんな固定概念持ってるでしょうに
ヨーロッパに対する固定概念
アメリカに対する固定概念
イギリスに対する固定概念
アフリカに対する固定概念
韓国に対する固定概念
中国に対する固定概念と
それでしか判断しようとしない
違うことを言っちゃったら
あんた変なことを言ってるんだと平気でそういうんです
だからそういう気持ちある限りは
頭がもう悪いまんまでまるっきり成長しない
なぜ？だから人類の中でなかなか天才が現れないんです
天才にはなれないんです
もう教えたものでそれで捕まって握ってるんだから
教えられたものは全く嘘なのに
あの あるインターネットで科学のある文章を読んだところで
いろいろ質問に答えるというところで
この味の感覚対して質問があって
で それに答えた人がこの神経の働きといろいろいろいろずっと書いてあって
この彼が言うのはこの舌のところでね
まあまあ どこでもまあ大雑把にいろいろ味は味わい
まあそれまあ厳密に言うと説明ありましたけどね
でも昔はこの舌を部分に分けて
ここら辺でこの味 ここら辺でこの味
ここら辺でこの味感じるんだと決めてあったんだと
でもそれは間違いだと
後から発見した事実から見ると
でもそれもすっごい昔なんで
そういうふうに舌を分けたのは
でも未だに学校でもどこでも大学でもそれ同じことを教えてるんだと
言って 彼がまあ答えそういうふうに答えだったんだけどね
ですから このいくら科学で言ったって
もう何か決めつけちゃったら
それだけでずっと言っちゃうんです
だから医学の場合 我々ひどい目にあってるんだから
何かこれは薬だと決めちゃったら
もう大騒ぎして この薬っていうのは
今人を治すよりは商売だから
新しい薬を発見したらもうすぐにできましたと
これでこれは治る これは治る
これは治ると 治るリスト見たら一切の病気治ります
で それでも半年間  1 年間経つと
まああれは使っちゃいけません
大変な危険だということになっちゃいます
そこまで使ったバカどもがどうなるということかと
最近また新しい薬が出ているんですね
それですごい大騒ぎしているんです
すごい高い薬ですけどね
それで若返るんだと で
やっぱり僕はその関係の資料も結構読みます
一人の人だけ あなた方はね
大騒ぎするな それどういう副作用あるかと
まだ分かってもないし
ですから この人がね 全く何の根拠もなく
ものすごい大マスコミして大騒ぎしてするてたってもね
そんな引かれないで とことん研究しながらデータを取りながら
もうあの とっても あの
何て言いますか アンダーコントロールのコントロールの中で使う人は使った方がよろしいんじゃないかと
その記事はたった一つで
これ応援する記事はものすごいもう大量にある
そういう風なこの世の中なんですね
で これは昔からもう例えば日本
昔日本だったら あの まあ昔鎖国的に国をね
外国と関係なかったけども
もう外国人すごい危ないとかなんとかと
で みんなそれでまあ外国人そう
まあ危ない もう決めつけちゃう
で それで性格がそのなりに変わっちゃうし
で それは事実かというと
それ事実じゃないし ですから仏教では何も決めつけない方がいいんです
で 条件いろいろ因縁をちゃんと見て
ああ 一応こういうふうにはなるんだと
言って 自分の心はいつでもオープンコンディションで
私はこの生き方でやるぞということはやめた方がいいんです
それはずいぶん悟りにはもう妨げになる
この願は人類みんな持ってるんです
あのavijjaとかvirupaとかね
その願にはもうたまたま人が起こされますけど
起こせますけど 番目の願では全ての人がやられてるんです
で ほとんどの人は悟らないのはこのあの
この願の組織の問題から言うと番目なんです
ですか たらまあ余計な話かもしれませんね
例えば大乗仏教の方々はもう大乗仏教に何か不満があったり
不満なかったり あるいはより知りたいとか
なんとかわけ 例えば初期仏教を勉強するすると
理解はしないだろう すぐ見えるんですね
なぜかというと やっぱりいろいろ固定概念があったりして
それにぴったしはめると認める
はめないとおかしいとする
それで真理を知ったわけにはならないんですね
自分の同じ古い考え方をまた持って運んだだけのことになっちゃうんですね
例えば ある宗派の人がテーラワーダのことをまあ初期仏教だからじゃあ勉強してみようかと来ても
どこら辺自分の教えと似ているかと
それだけを探しに来ると
何も勉強したことにならないんですね
自分持ってきたゴミを同じゴミをコンクリートで固めてまた持って帰ると
より捨て難くすると それで知識人にはならないんです
知識人っていうのは もう真理が見つかったら
今までの嘘は全部何も惜しくなく捨てるぐらいの勇気がないと
仏教はそういう人になってほしいと言っているんですね
四千年間ぐらい信じてきたっても嘘だと分かったら
もうすっと捨てる それはもう簡単に
たとえ喧嘩にいったっても嘘だと分かったら
まあ嘘やとすぐもう 我々にはできないでしょうね
誰かが偉い人が何か言ったらそれだけのことで信じるんだから
一番日本で信じがたい方法っていうのは
もう高校もろくに卒業していないこの子供たちいるでしょ
タレントさんたちが あの人もあの宗教団体に入ってるんだって聞いたら
それでも全部行ってそこに入るんです
沢口敬子入ったんだからって言って
あの真如苑ですか インチキ集団がね
ものすごい あそこでしたか
あの娘はもう可愛いしね
まあすごい 上手なね 女優さんですけど
まあそれはそれで だからって全ての生命の真理だからわかるっていうこと？それでいくんだから
ですから そういうのはよく理解して
我々の心はね なぜ我々にはものすごい膨大な智慧がないかというと
そういうこの願があるんだから
で 平気でみんな言うんですね
何々さんもこちらに行きましたよと
誰かさんが誰かの喫茶店に行って紅茶飲んだんだからといって
それでみんなそこに行くと
それではたまたまそこに行く場所もなかったんだから行ったかもしれませんけど
まあそれぐらいのことで決めつけちゃう
そういう性格は勉強できない料なんですね
人間が天才になれない料なんです
明日スリランカでものすごい有名なお坊さんが亡くなって百三歳
で まあ葬式ありますけどね
百三歳までもすごい元気でものすごい稼いでていたんですけど
いろんな大学から来た博士号やらと稼ぐとものすごい大量になるんで
すごい学者なんです でも全部捨てる
自分の宗派の大長老でしたけど
で それ以前から捨てちゃったんです
私は一般のお坊さんになりたいんだ
そんな位なんかは要りませんって言ってこの寺を出しちゃったって
寺を出したってそのお坊さんの代わりに決める人はいないんですね
大体宗派の一番偉い人にするのはね
一番もう学問的にも歳も上でも有名な
まあそれなりに素晴らしい人を選ぶんだけど
宗派困って困ってどうしようかと
でもその人は要りません
そんなこと それほど危ないものはないんだ
すっごい性格なんですね
そのお坊さんがこの九十歳になってからかな
コンピューターを勉強して
九十歳あとはないです
ですからコンピューター入ったのはもう十年ぐらいのことだから
まあそのそこそこでそこでもそれ現れたし
もうお坊さんももうじゃあこれはもう年だから
もう先がないんだから
私にはいいわ そんなことないんです
そうと言って それで勉強して
まあインターネットやらああだこうだとかね
まあこうすればいいんだ
こういうこういう風に
まあ簡単にこれから説法する時でもできるんだとか
他の若いものなんだってね
いろいろ言ったりして
だからこの 何と言いますか
ボケるということはもうそうないんで
そういう言葉さえも どんな若い人に
か あちらの方がずいぶん頭がもう冴えてるんです
私のある弟子の若い人がなんかメッセージが何か欲しいことでね
長老に会ったみたいですね
会ったらまず怒ったんですね
あんた方はね こんなくだらないことにこちらに来るなと言ったら
もうなんでこんな大長老が怒るんですから
もうわからないでしょ
若い人は だからこう言うんですね
あんた方はね 私は今大事なテキストを書いてるんだと
私にはこの 一分  一秒っていうのはすごく大事ですよと
もう先がないんだと ですから
あなたと五分喋るということはもうとんでもないことだと
言って その瞬間 その人はすごい事実を教えちゃったんですね
だから自分がもうその時はもしかすると歳にそろそろだと思いますけどね
自分にはもう日にち決まってるでしょうに
ですから決めた何か大変な学問的なテキストなんですけど
それは編集して直そうと思ったんだから
一秒一秒でも無駄にしないでちゃんとすぐやらないと
そこで先生どうですかね
体の調子はとかね 何か飲み物でも持っていきましょうか？あれすごい迷惑なんです
あの時間はね ですから
そういう風にこのすごい知識の人になれるということは
この心はいつでも何か掴まれない状態で
この日本で有名なこのクリシュナムーティとかね
今もいるこのサイ・ババとか
みんな仲良しなんです
その人と ティトモテ亡くなりましたけどね
すごい仲良しで それでヒンドゥー教の巨大な学者だこうだとか
そのお坊さんのことというのは随分よく知っていて
それでダライ・ラマさんでもね
スリランカの誰かに会ったら
どうですか？私の先生は元気ですか？と聞くぐらいもう大変な人なんです
で ミャンマー政府ではミャンマーのお坊さんにもあげない
もう一番最高な位をね
まあ国のお坊さんという名前
日本で昔あったんですね
そういう そういうタイトルあげてるんです
それを他の誰にもあげたことはない
何をあげたって そのお坊さんが全然見ようともしないぐらい
だから弟子たちが衣汚れていますよと言わないと
それも気にしないぐらいでしたからね
先生 衣汚れてるのに あ
そうというぐらいで見ないで
こうやって 忙しいと で
ですからこの僕にいろんな若い坊さんたちがいますよ
あまり個人的に付き合ったことはないんだけどね
言うのはもうあのお坊さんに水が欲しいと言ったら
水いっぱい持っていくことぐらいも
これ大変な勉強になるんだと
水いっぱい持って行って挨拶して帰る
その瞬間で何か言うんですね
あれでもすごい勉強になるんだ
あれぐらいのことで ですからまあ誰でもお世話したがっちゃうぐらいの
スリランカの政治も前はものすごい厳密に共産主義をやってた政治家がいたんです
すごい政治家だからずっとまあ投票では選ばれるし
ものすごい経済学者で
でも経済政治的には共産主義
共産主義というよりはこの違う共産主義の違う宗派があるんですね
トロツキーさん トロツキー
で 国民にはなかなか好ってかった人でしたけど
なぜかというと この独立する時はすっごい活動してくれたんですね
あの植民地の反対運動の時とか
ですから愛されてはいたんだけど
どうせ政権は取れませんし
で 仏教なんか宗教なんかまるっきりもう嫌いですね
嫌いんだけど 彼が自分の遺言書に
もし私が先に死んだら
私の葬式を仏教的に今亡くなっている長老にやっていただいたら
と遺言書を書いて亡くなったんです
亡くなったら その長老は長老は年上ですけどね
あの人はよりはね 長老はちゃんと葬式に
なかなかそんなことにはいかないんですけど
やっぱりそうだったらという弟子なんです
ですから 私はその例を出したのは
この歳になって ゴロゴロの体で体細いんだから
自由はあると 全部歩くことは何らかの自由でしたけどね
コンピューターをいじるということは
あれはガキがやることなんですけど
僕ではあまりやりたくないんです
もうあんまりにもこの考え方のレベルが低いんです
コンピューターの中のからくりっていうのは
ですから複雑でもないしね
子供には合うんだと それでもやっぱり現代知識だからとやるぞという風な
あの気持ちは素晴らしいんですね
私はもう年だからとかね
もう時代 私の時代違うんだからとか
それはない ですから とてもあの
それは仏教的な精神なんですね
日本にいるある若い坊さんにも博士研究をやっているんだけど
どうかと 僕もいたところで
もうあんたね まだ若いんだからね
私よりはね もっと新しいことをいろいろみんなに言いなさいと
私は休みますと言ったら
もう先生とはもうどうやって喋るんだ
先生は年先にいるんだからと（笑）
と返って私に怒られちゃうんですね
僕はそうじゃないんだと
あんた方もちょっと我々の真似をしてね
きちんといつでも心をね
オープンにしなさいと
それで言って とにかく私は喋ったんだけどね
だからそこではすごくちょっと悲しくなっちゃったんですね
で もう歳も飛んでいる私と
もう歳にもなってない人が
私は年先を考えてるんだと言われると
将来はどうなるんですかと
このその連中でしょうに
将来は仏教を持っていくのは
だから今そちらが僕らより先に知識を飛んでいかないとね
でもこれは事実だと掴めない限り
心は自由にしておくと
もう何のことなく いくらいくらでも人間に知恵が発達してきます
じゃあそれは即的な話で
なんで仏教の悟りにこれ関わりあるかというと
何かこれ事実だ これ悟りだ
捕まったらそこで悟りではなくなっちゃうんですね
例えば人に魂があるんだと思っても構いません
当然知りませんだから
そこで何かちょっと体の変化が体験したところで
瞑想で あ これはいわゆる魂やと決めちゃったら
全く古い考え方でしょうに
そういう傾向があると全く悟れないんです
あ こういうことはこういうことだ
こういうことをずっと解釈するでしょうに
だから私たちはずっと解釈は毒だ
解釈はやめろ ヴィパッサナーでは解釈は禁物と
解釈しないで体験するものは体験して体験して先行き行ってください
解釈するということは
持っている固定概念に比べるということ
固定概念合っちゃったら気持ちよく
やったぞやったぞと あれこそ無知なんです
[咳]違う宗派の違う宗教の人が私たちのところに来て
初期仏教を勉強しようと
その人は自分の宗教がどこら辺似ているかということを見つかるために来たならば
何かそういう似ていることを聞いたならばすごい喜んで
やっぱりすごいんだこれはと言って
帰って何を持っていくんですかね
ただ単に自分持ってきた固定概念を持ってくだけでしょうに
やっぱり我々の教えは間違わなかったと
釈迦様の教え勉強したところでもやっぱり同じでしたということの結論でしょう
あれでもう終わりなんですね
ですから 瞑想する人々っていうのは
いつでもこの固定概念
解釈してはこれは固定概念なんですね
ですから どんな人間もこの番目の願はあります
番目の願あるんだから
人間にはなかなか勉強するのは難しい
いくらか勉強して それで落ち着いて
それっきり何も聞こうと思おうと考えようともしないと
それでもおいこぶれになって社会から追い出される
もし頭がきれいにしておけば
歳飛んでも社会のは避けられるんです
イギリスのベルトラッセルという哲学者にしたってもね
死ぬ瞬間までもうすごい哲学者なんです
歳になった時も結婚するんですね
歳なんですけど 若い人と結婚する
やっぱりもう 固定概念がないんですね
だからそういう人々がもう天才なんです
新しいものはすぐ見つかるし
それによって古いものは違うとわかったらすぐ捨てるし
だからって新しい見つかったものを捕まってるかってそうでもないし
それにまたチャレンジしてみる
本当かな そういうわけで
天才になるのはそんな難しいことじゃないんです
だから私が言ったのは
この一応我々の学校なんかでは
必ずこの学校で何を教えるかという固定概念
叩き込んじゃうんですね
差別概念 差別必要ではないか
これはこれだけ事実だよと
それでもうもうもうそれはもう人殺しみたいな教育なんですね
そうじゃなくて 一応先生はこう言うんだけど
違う立場から見れば違う意見でもあるかもしれませんよとかね
歴史は勉強すると 一応今まで我々知ってる情報ではこういうことだけですけど
もし違う情報が入ったら
これ全部グッと変わる可能性もありますよと
科学の勉強でもね 今はもうこの教科書から見ればこういうことなんですけど
これからどうなることやらわかりませんと
そういう風に教えてあげなくちゃいけないんです
私は知ってる限りはまあこれぐらいしか私は知りませんと
もっと違うかもしれませんですから
どうぞ頑張ってみてくださいと
どんなものについてあっても
そういう風に言わなくちゃいけない
そういう自由な心が心をちょっと育ててあげると
すごい人間にはなるんです
だから子供の場合はやりやすいんだけど
何か考え方つかまっちゃったらすぐそれ壊しちゃうと
そこで次の考え方つかまっちゃう
それも壊しちゃうと そこで何言ったっても壊されるんだから
ものすごく頭が鋭くなるんですね
もう何回も私は試したこともありますけどね
やっぱりみるみるうちに頭がもう成長することをすっごい強烈に成長するんですね
いえ これはこういうことだよとは言わないと
本人が一生懸命発見して
これはこういうことですと言った途端
もう違うことを言って
でもこういうこういう風に見ちゃうと
そんなものじゃないんですよと言って答えは言わない
だからどういうことかと
それで困ったと 本人の意見は壊されたんだから
また頑張っちゃう 頑張って新しい意見を持ってくる
それでそれも壊しちゃうと
それで何になるかというと
この真理を探すべきだということになるし
見つかってもすぐ捨てられるもんだと
新しいことにいくべきということが分かります
それは普通の世界にも大いに必要なことなんです
イダン・サッチャー・ディニウェイ・サッチャー
時々ありますね 例えば仏教はいいことだなとわかっても
やっぱり私はそうとカトリック教でいたんだからね
やっぱりどうしますかとかね
どうしますかね その場合
これはカトリック教であろうが何教であろうがね
うっそうと発見したら捨てるもんであって
何か尊いものあるんですかね
世の中に 何もないんです
例えば人間にお墓いりませんって言ったら
やっぱりそう言ったっても
やっぱり日本ではね ずっとやってるんだから
何がそこに価値があるんですかね
ずっとやってることに価値があるんですかね
だけど どんな愚かなことでも
ずっとやるんだったら価値があるということになっちゃうんですね
それで本当にこのこれだければすごい革命的な
大胆にも先進的な もう限りない知恵に心が現れる道になっちゃう
で 悟りっていうのはまたそちらの結果にもなるわけですね
そういうわけで ほとんどの人の悟りを妨げているのは
このこれは事実だ これは真理だと
このずいぶんしがみ込む性格なんです
で ちょっと長い時間喋りましたから
ちょっと休憩して 十分で
え？何？うん まあいいや
組織だから まあちょっとややこしくてね
我々の悟りを妨げてる組織四ですね
アーヤガミ で それからウパーダーナという言葉で
また解脱を妨げているものを説明するわけですね
で ほとんど内容は似ています
ウパーダーナという四つあるんですね
ウパーダーナの場合は自分で捕まってるという意味なんですね
それは割れてるというよりは
取っていると 捕まってるという意味なんで
自分が だから心の働き
いろいろ組織的にやられてる場合もあるし
ただ結ばれているような
もうどうしようもない時もあるし
自分につなげている自分の体に言われる
それはヨーガですね 何て言いますか
この首置きですか 首置き的にも我々邪魔されているし
いろんな方法あります
これこの場合は自分で取っている
何かね 支えないんだから何か捕まってるでしょ
人っていうのは何かね
精神的にちょっと不安定
何かあったら何か捕まってるんですね
そんな感じで自分の生命が何か捕まってるんですね
四つのこと 捕まってるんだから輪廻に推進を捕まってるんです
なかなか抜けられなくて
それは これはあんまり難しくない
カーマ・ウパーダーナ
カーマ あとは あとはディッティ・ウパーダーナ
ディッティ・カーマ・ディッティ・シーラ
カーマ・ディッティ・シーラ